(mysterious piano music)
- I am honored
to introduce to you,
the creator of the Hunger Games
themselves,
Dean Casca Highbottom.
- I have summoned you all here
for the
10th Annual Reaping Ceremony,
in which we choose two
children from each District
to fight to the death
in the Hunger Games.
- [District 12 Announcer] From
District 12, Lucy Gray Baird.
- There has been
a change this year.
As a Mentor, Mr. Snow,
your role is to turn these
children into spectacles,
not survivors.
- What does my mentor do
besides bring me roses?
- I do my best
to take care of you.
- You really wanna take
care of me in that Arena?
Start by thinking
I can actually win.
(dramatic orchestral music)
- I'm Lucky Flickerman,
first ever host
of the Hunger Games.
- [Announcer] Enjoy the show.
- [Lucky Flickerman] Five.
Four.
- [Announcer] Enjoy the show.
- [Lucky Flickerman] Three.
Two.
- [Announcer] Enjoy the show.
- Run.
(alarm rings)
- [Announcer] Enjoy the show.
- What happens in there,
fueled with the terror
of becoming prey,
see how quickly
we become predator?
See how quickly
civilization disappears?
(dramatic orchestral
music continues)
- There's a natural
goodness built into us all.
We can step across
that line into evil,
or not.
- You hear that, boy?
It's the sound of snow...
falling.
- How wonderful that
we all get to be here,
for someone's final performance.
- It's not just about winning.
- Everything is about winning.
- You're monsters,
all of you!
(Dr. Gaul laughs)
(dramatic orchestral
music continues)
(officer shouts)
(soldiers grunt)
- [Snow]
It's the things we love most,
that destroy us.
(dramatic orchestral
music continues)
(Rue's Four Note Song plays)